เฮ
[Música]
Olá,
boa noite a todos. É um prazer estar
aqui com vocês.
Boa noite, Dra. Ana Paula, que está
acompanhando ao vivo. À medida que vocês
forem entrando, por favor, dê o seu alô
e me digam se o áudio está OK.
Bem, como é de pra nós vamos começar
agora a responder as dúvidas e depois a
gente vai
discutir um assunto aqui interessante
que eu separei para vocês.
Primeira pergunta.
Você disse uma live passada que na sua
opinião o autismo era várias doenças.
Sim, para mim não é uma doença só, é um
espectro, né? A própria doença fala
transtorno espectro autista,
que são várias condições em uma só, e
que 5% dos casos de autismo pode ter
chance de cura. A literatura fala entre
1 a 5%.
Você poderia falar mais sobre isso?
Vamos lá, vamos falar sobre autismo.
Então, o transtorno espectro autista,
ele é entendido pela comunidade
científica como um conjunto de condições
com múltiplas causas, como eu já te
falei, não é uma única doença com origem
uniforme. Então, esse termo espectro,
ele reflete justamente essa diversidade.
Tem diferentes formas de apresentação,
quadros leves, quadros moderados e
graves. E tem também dentro desse
guarda-chuva a síndrome de Aspinger e
também, né, o a síndrome de Savã.
Então, a gente sabe que há uma
combinação de fatores genéticos, fatores
ambientais,
é bem complexo.
Existe, por exemplo, a situação da
síndrome do X frágil. a gente conhece
aí
uma enfermeira que tem um filho já hoje
com 30 anos com essa condição, né?
E essa sínoma do X frágil também
conhecida como síndrome de Het e o
autismo é um dos sintomas. Então, o
autismo é muito complexo.
Então, realmente isso reforça a ideia de
que estamos diante de múltiplas doenças
ou síndromes que compartilham
manifestações comportamentais
semelhantes.
Então, a comunidade científica, de modo
geral, não aceita o termo cura,
pelo menos no sentido tradicional da
palavra, mas tem relatos, tem evidências
de que existe essa percentagem de 5% de
indivíduos que poderiam deixar de
apresentar os sintomas do espectro ao
longo do desenvolvimento.
revistas científicas publicaram estudos
que a ponto de entre 1 a 5% das crianças
diagnosticadas antes dos 5 anos podem,
após intervenções intensivas e
acompanhamento, não apresentar mais
sintomas suficientes
para manter o diagnóstico na
adolescência ou vida adulta.
Teve um estudo que crianças que deixaram
de apresentar os sintomas do espectro,
elas foram avaliadas e se mostraram com
desempenho semelhante ao de crianças
típicas em testes comportamentais.
Então, algumas apresentaram
características de TDH, mas não mais os
critérios para autismo. Veja como essas
coisas são complexas e como é que elas
se misturam.
Então, ainda não se sabe exatamente
porque que isso ocorre, né? Porque que
tem casos que podem reverter e outros
não. Obviamente tem muito a ver com
estilo de vida e com a intensidade do
tratamento, né? Quanto melhor o estilo
de vida e mais intenso tratamento,
mais provável que isso vai acontecer.
E tem a hipótese que tem fatores
neurogenéticos que vão predispor alguns
indivíduos a superar a condição,
especialmente quando existe intervenção
rápida, precoce e intensa.
Então, existe pesquisas experimentais,
como é o caso do biólogo Alisson Muotre,
que demonstrou em laboratório que
neurônios derivados de pessoas com
autismo, tratados com certas drogas
experimentais, como é o caso do GF1, né,
que é o Insulin Grow Factor 1, poderiam
reverter as características para níveis
de normalidade, sugerindo que ao menos
em nível celular o autismo poderia ser
reversível em alguns casos. Entretanto,
isso ainda está no âmbito experimental.
Isso não representa de nenhuma maneira
uma cura clínica, abre caminho para
novas pesquisas e novas abordagens, né?
Hã,
então essa era as considerações que eu
queria falar sobre esse assunto. Se você
que tiver ao vivo e quiser que eu
explique mais alguma coisa específica,
sua disposição, tá? Boa noite, Alice
Vogel. Boa noite, Inara, tá
acompanhando.
Bem, próxima pergunta
da Próinara, né, que tá acompanhando ao
vivo aí.
Como usar betaalanina? Qualquer pessoa
pode. Betalanina é muito seguro porque é
aminoácido, né? Então é bem tranquilo,
tem alguns cuidados, tem alguns
pormenoras que eu vou falar a respeito.
Então a dose usual da betalanina é de 2
a 5 g por dia. Pode se dividir em
menores doses ao longo do dia, porque o
efeito colateral que não é perigoso,
mais comum dela é o formigamento na
pele, né, que é bem parecido com o
formigamento que acontece com uso doses
altas de neacina, tá? Então, a
betalanina também causa vaso dilatação
igual a anacina em outras doses. Por
isso que fisiculturistas ou praticantes
de atividade física gostam muito de usar
betalanina para aumentar a circulação
arterial dos músculos e aumentar o
desempenho.
Se você não está acostumado com
betalanina, comece com doses menores de
1 a 2 g ao dia e vai aumentando conforme
a tolerância. e não tem um horário
específico. Você pode consumir qualquer
horário antes, depois do treino. A
maioria do pessoal prefere tomar antes
do treino para dar aquele pump muscular.
Mas o mais importante, sem dúvida, é o
uso diário, é o uso consistente.
Então, para melhores resultados,
suplementação, ela deve ser mantida por
pelo menos um mês, quatro semanas,
porque a betalanina precisa se acumular
nos tecidos, nos músculos, para aumentar
os níveis de carnosina, né, que vai
fazer aquele efeito de tampô, de tampão,
né,
celular, né, que ele faz para bloquear
aí a acidose metabólica do exercício.
E aí vai proporcionar benefícios como
resistência e redução da fadiga.
E você pode misturar em qualquer
líquido, em água, suco, shake, bebida da
sua preferência. Dividir a dose ao longo
do dia, como eu falei, pode ser uma boa
para minimizar esse formigamento que eu
comentei e pode ser combinado livremente
com outros suplementos, como o Protein,
como outras proteínas de outras origens.
Você pode combinar com creatina, com
glutamina, com carboidrato, não tem
nenhum problema. as combinações,
como eu disse, existe risco de
formigamento na pele, que pode incomodar
muitas pessoas. Pega principalmente
rosto, pescoço e mãos, é temporário e
diminui com o uso contínuo, você vai se
acostumando, isso vai reduzindo.
Existe pessoas que relatam dor de
estômago, náusea, com o uso, né, da
betalanina em jejum. Então, preste
atenção a isso se você tiver, então você
pode estar tomando junto com refeições.
Em casos raros, pode haver uma queda nos
níveis de taurina usando a betalanina.
E a taurina, você sabe que é importante
pro cérebro, importante para funções
cardiovasculares
e pro equilíbrio de eletrólitos. Então é
uma coisa rara, mas que vocês devem
prestar atenção.
O uso é seguro, como eu falei para
maioria das pessoas, em gestantes, como
sempre, em lactantes, como sempre, e em
crianças pequenas,
deve-se evitar o uso, porque a gente tem
pouca informação nesses grupos,
tem pouco estudo sobre segurança nesses
grupos.
Pessoas que têm pressão alta,
hipertensão ou problemas
cardiovasculares também deve tomar um
certo cuidado por falta de informações.
Então, pessoas que têm sensibilidade à
parestesia, né, que não se sente bem ou
tem muita facilidade de ter parestesia,
que é formigamento, deve evitar também
de usar a betalanina
e pode influenciar a pressão arterial,
por isso cautela em pessoas com
histórico de pressão alta.
dose já foi falado, mas eu vou repetir.
São 2 a 5 g ao dia divididos ao longo do
dia, ok? E use pelo menos 4 semanas para
ter um resultado expressivo,
certo? Então, principal indicação é
melhora de performance em atividade
física, diminui a fadiga muscular e
aumenta o fluxo arterial para os
músculos.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
U, mesma pergunta. Repetiu. Deixa eu
ver.
É verdade, tá repetida a pergunta.
Ah, Eliseu, ingeri creatina, esqueci de
comer banana logo em seguida, porém
depois me lembrei, mas ainda não sei se
dá tempo. Não se preocupe com isso,
Eliseu. Não vai fazer tanta diferença
assim. tomar com a banana ou não. OK? Se
você quiser, você pode ingerir essa
banana até horas depois, porque a
creatina ela fica armazenada no
organismo, tá? Ela não é consumida
imediatamente.
O consumo de carboidratos junto com a
creatina, sim, pode ajudar a aumentar a
liberação da insulina durante o
exercício, que facilitaria o transporte
da creatina para dentro das células.
Então é uma boa, mas não é obrigatória
associar creatina com fonte de
carboidrato de médio índice gliccêêmico.
E também nos estudos não tem uma janela
de tempo exata e rígida. O consenso
prático que a ingestão de carboidrato
pode ser feita junto ou logo após a
creatina, preferencialmente até 30 a 60
minutos depois da suplementação, porque
o pico de insulina gerado pelo
carboidrato vai ocorrer nesse período e
vai favorecer, então favorecer não quer
dizer que vai impedir se você não tomar
junto, né? Então, o carboidrato favorece
então o transporte de creatina para o
músculo.
Então, se você esqueceu de comer a
banana junto, você pode comer depois até
uma hora após tomar a creatina, que
ainda terá o benefício aí do do aumento
de transporte.
Logicamente, o mais importante é a
regularidade do uso da creatina, não é a
questão do horário em si. Tomar creatina
de forma isolada é eficaz também.
E a diferença de associar com
carboidrato
é mais relevante para quem é atleta de
alta performance, né, ou que tem faz um
treino muito intenso.
Então não esquente a cabeça com essa
história aí de horário. Certo?
Próxima pergunta.
O biquinol recicla
as vitaminas C e E.
Mesmo que o biquinol seja ingerido
muitas horas depois ou antes da ingestão
das vitaminas C e E. Que que é o
bikquinol? Para quem não sabe, é a forma
reduzida da com enzima Q10.
É fundamental na regeneração dos
antioxidantes liposolúveis. vai ajudar a
reciclar esses antioxidantes,
especialmente a vitamina E,
alfotocoferol e também os tocotrienois,
e pode participar da reciclagem da
vitamina C em certos contextos. Então, o
mecanismo envolve a redução do radical
tocoferoxil, que é a vitamina E oxidada
de volta famiva, né, tocoferol,
permitindo que a vitamina E continue
protegendo as membranas celulares contra
a perxidação lipídica.
Vamos falar sobre o timing da reciclagem
antioxidante.
O biquinol, ele reduz o radical
tocoferoxil
a tocoferol, enquanto a vitamina C pode
regenerar a vitamina E no meio acoso,
criando uma rede, né, sinérgica. Ou
seja,
tanto no meio acoso quanto no meio
gorduroso pode haver essa questão aí da
recuperação da vitamina E.
Então, após ingestão, tanto o biquinol
quanto as vitaminas C e E são
absorvidos, tribuídos e armazenados em
diferentes compartimentos celulares e
membranas. E a conversão entre o
biquinon e o biquinol ocorre
continuamente, né? A forma inativa ou a
forma ativa conforme a demanda do
organismo por redox, né, por questões aí
de antioxidação.
Então não é necessário que o biquinol, a
vitamina C e a vitamina E sejam sejam
ingeridos exatamente ao mesmo tempo para
que ocorra a reciclagem. O organismo
mantém reservas substâncias em
compartimentos celulares, com exceção da
vitamina C, né, que a reserva é muito
curta e elas podem interagir sempre que
estiverem presentes nos mesmos
compartimentos, independente do momento
exato da ingestão.
Estudos em animais e humanos
experimentais mostram que a
suplementação
combinada de o biquinol ou biquinona e
vitamina E resulta em efeitos
antioxidantes sinérgicos sem
administração simultânea. Então não
precisa ser simultâneo. O importante é
que ambos estejam presentes nos tecidos
durante os períodos de estresse
oxidativo.
E o biquinol, a biquinona são
rapidamente
interconvertidos no organismo. A
coenzima Q10 circulante é
predominantemente na forma reduzida
biquinol, que está pronta para atuar
como reciclador de outras vitaminas,
inclusive a E indiretamente de vitamina
C.
E a absorção de biquinol é relativamente
lenta, o pico no sangue entre 6 a 8
horas e a vitamina E armazenada nas
membranas lipídicas por longos períodos.
Assim, mesmo com diferença de horas na
ingestão, ambos podem estar disponíveis
simultaneamente nos tecidos.
Então, conclusão, o biquinol pode
reciclar as vitaminas C e E mesmo que
seja ingerido muitas horas antes ou
depois das vitaminas, desde que haja
sobreposição de suas presenças nos
compartimentos celulares relevantes.
OK.
Próxima pergunta.
É verdade que banhe com sabonete mata a
microbiota presente na superfície da
pele? Alguns usam esse argumento para
dizer que ao tomar banho é melhor não
passar sabonete na superfície da pele e
que apenas a água é suficiente para
tirar o suor.
Bem, sabonetes comuns, que não são
aqueles microbianos, né,
antimicrobianos, tipo aquela maca famosa
lá, os comuns não matam a microbiota da
pele. Eles removem a camada de gordura
lipídica da superfície, não eliminam as
bactérias benéficas de forma
significativa.
Apenas os bactericidas ou
antibacterianos
têm o potencial de eliminar parte
relevante da microbiota cutânea e
podendo assim prejudicar o equilíbrio do
ecossistema. Então, uso frequente
sabonetes agressivos, bactericidas ou
esfoliantes pode sim causar
desequilíbrio, ressecamento e até
favorecer o surgimento de problemas
dematológicos porque afeta a barreira
protetora da pele. Então, não usa
aqueles sabonetes famosos que alegam que
matam 99,9% das bactérias.
OK? Tomar banho só com água vai remover
o suor, superficialmente a sujeira e os
resíduos.
E poderia ser suficiente para higiene
básica em situações de pouca exposição à
sujeira ou pouco suor. No entanto, na
realidade da maior parte do Brasil, que
é quente,
o sabonete é altamente recomendado,
especialmente em áreas como axilas, pés
e região genital, porque senão você vai
certamente acumular odores e proliferar
algumas bactérias indesejáveis.
E o banho diário com água fria ou morna
não vai comprometer a camada de sebo da
pele natural, desde que não seja
excessivamente longo ou com água
excessivamente quente,
tá? Então não usem os sabonetes
antibacterianos, eles são
desnecessários, até são prejudiciais.
Use sabonetes suaves,
sabonetes comuns mesmo, sem detergentes
agressivos.
E
não é obrigatório realmente usar
sabonete todo dia, a não ser que você
sue bastante. Eu acredito que na maior
parte do Brasil não faria sentido ficar
sem usar o sabonete. OK.
Próxima pergunta.
A carência de um micronutriente
vai interferir diretamente na função de
vários outros, desencadeando uma reação
em cascata e desequilibrando a função.
Isso é possível de acontecer, né, em
algumas circunstâncias. Por exemplo, se
vamos falar de ferro, vitamina A e
zinco, a deficiência de um desses
micronutrientes pode prejudicar absorção
e utilização dos animais. Por exemplo, o
zinco é necessária paraa síntese de
proteína transportadora da vitamina A. A
deficiência de ferro compromete a
absorção intestinal de vitamina A e a
deficiência de vitamina A pode agravar
quadros de anemia porque a sua
suplementação
estimula a mobilização hepática de
ferro, tá? Então, existe essa conversa
entre o ferro, a vitamina A e o zinco.
Altas doses de ferro podem reduzir a
absorção de zinco, dependendo da relação
entre ambos e da via de administração.
Então, suplementar isoladamente quando
possível é bom, né, um isolado do outro,
né, o ferro, do zinco e do cobre, se for
possível.
E também se você exagerar na
suplementação de um desses itens
isoladamente, você pode estar
prejudicando outros também.
Vamos falar então de algumas
deficiências em conjunto.
Por exemplo, deficiência de ferro,
zinco, selênio, vitamina A e C vão ter
efeito sobre a imunidade, aumentando a
suscetibilidade a infecções e
inflamações recorrentes.
Então é importante estar observando
esses minerais em conjunto,
ferro, zincos, selene, vitaminas A e C,
além da vitamina D, obviamente
em crianças a carência de
micronutrientes está relacionada ao
déficit de crescimento linear, atraso
desenvolvimento neurológico e maior
morbibortalidade.
No sistema músculoesquelético, né, a
falta de vitamina D e cálcio comprometem
a formação dos ossos, aumentando o risco
de osteopenia, osteoporose, fratura. E a
deficiência de magnésio e proteínas
interfere na função muscular, causando
fraqueza e dores. A deficiência de ferro
é a principal causa de anemia
ferropriva, afeta por volta de 25% da
população mundial
e a deficiência de B12 pode causar
neuropatia periférica e anemia também,
só que anemia megaloblástica. Então, a
B12 tem uma conversa aí com o ferro,
assim como o cálcio conversa com a
vitamina D
e carências múltiplas em situações
específicas podem levar a disfunções
metabólicas como resistência à insulina
e pressão alta e gordura alta no sangue
de lipidemia.
Então, a deficiência de um
micronutriente raramente ocorra de forma
isolada. Normalmente ela compromete
rotas metabólicas compartilhadas e isso
pode levar a prejuízos funcionais em
cadeia. Por exemplo, a deficiência de
vitamina D pode reduzir a absorção de
cálcio, afetando os ossos, a imunidade,
o metabolismo energético.
Da mesma forma, a deficiência de ferro
pode prejudicar o metabolismo da
vitamina A zinco.
Certo?
Vamos para a próxima aqui.
Reciclar vitamina C no corpo implica que
irá impedir a oxidação da vitamina C.
Bem, não sei se eu entendi essa pergunta
do jeito que ela foi formulada, mas
vamos lá tentar responder isso aqui. O
que que significaria reciclar a vitamina
C? Já falamos disso agora a pouco, né?
Falando do biquinol, falando como é que
o biquinol pode reciclar a vitamina E a
vitamina C também pode reciclar a
vitamina E. A própria vitamina C, ela
pode virar um radical livre, né? Ela
pode virar o ascorbil, OK? Então tem a
gluta que pode reverter essa oxidação,
outros antioxidantes podem ajudar.
Então, no contexto bioquímico, reciclar
vitamina C se refere à capacidade
do organismo restaurar a forma reduzida
ativa do ácido ascórbico a partir de
suas formas oxidadas, né? Como eu falei,
o ascorbil virá de volta à vitamina C.
Tem também a forma oxidada ácido desidro
ascórbico.
Então esse processo de recuperação da
vitamina C ocorre por meio de sistemas
enzimáticos e não enzimáticos,
permitindo que a vitamina C continue
exercendo a sua função antioxidante.
A vitamina C é um bom antioxidante, mas
se oxida facilmente. Então ele ao doar
elétrons para neutralizar outros
radicais livres para proteger nossas
moléculas contra oxidação, ele se torna
também um radical livre. Então ele forma
as questões oxidadas como radical
ascorbil ou ascorbila e o que eu falei
também o ácido desidroascóbico.
E o que que acontece após oxidação? O
radical ascorbil ou ascorbila, ele é
relativamente estável. Ele pode ser
reconvertido em ácido ascóbico por
enzimas redutasis, que depende de Nad H,
ou por reações de desmutação. E o ácido
desidroascórbico, ele pode ser reduzido
de volta ao ácido ascórbico
por sistemas celulares, principalmente
gluta e outros tióis como doadores de
elétron.
Pergunta: "A reciclagem impede a
oxidação?" Não. A vitamina C, ela pode
ficar
eh numa roda aí, né? oxida, reduz,
oxida, reduz, né? A reciclagem não vai
impedir a oxidação da vitamina. O
processo de oxidação, ele é essencial
para que a vitamina C atue como
antioxidante. Então, ela precisa ser
oxidada para ela poder neutralizar os
radicais livres das células para
proteger as moléculas do organismo. E o
que a reciclagem faz é restaurar a
vitamina C a sua condição ativa após ela
ter sido oxidada, permitindo que ela
seja oxidada novamente, ou seja, exerça
as suas funções antioxidantes. Então,
ela pode ficar oxidada e virar reduzida.
oxidada, reduzida, oxidada, reduzida,
tá?
Então, a reciclagem da vitamina Crucial
para manter a atividade antioxidante
contínua. Além de neutralizar radicais
livres diretamente, a vitamina C também
regenera outros antioxidantes, como a
vitamina E, como eu comentei na outra
pergunta, e pode reciclar enzimas
antioxidantes, como as peroxirredoxinas,
ampliando a proteção contra o estresse
oxidativo.
Tá bom? Não sei se eu respondi a
pergunta,
mas é isso que eu tinha para falar desse
assunto.
Vamos responder mais umas poucas
perguntas aqui e partir para o
artiguinho que eu separei.
Um beijo para Alice Vgger tá falando de
Portugal.
Doutor Alão, o que você acha da vacina
para gripe? Não gosto dessa vacina,
Enild. Eu acho ela muito ineficiente,
tá?
Eu acho que na maioria dos casos ela não
ajuda tanto.
Excesso de clara de ovo tem potencial
alergênico para algumas pessoas? Sim,
mas não é por causa do excesso da clara,
porque tem umas pessoas que têm
tendência a alergia à clara independente
da quantidade. Seis ovos cozidos por dia
representa excesso de clara de ovo? Não,
não representa excesso. Como eu disse, o
problema não é a quantidade, é a pessoa
ter ou não suscetibilidade
a alergia à clara de ovo.
Algum problema em comer carne com
quinoa? Não, não tem.
De nada, Nara.
Boa noite, Isaac.
Aim, batata doce, inhame, cenoura e
beterraba. Cada um desses cinco
alimentos possui carboidrato suficiente
para aumentar a absorção de creatina?
Sim.
O DME seria um bom suplemento visando
potencializar memória?
Sim, é um bom suplemento para isso.
Você endossa teoria da linha de Hartman?
Não tenho certeza se essa teoria é real
ou não, sabe? Eu tenho um pouco de
dúvida.
cobertor de bioaterramento
protege do cruzamento.
Tem muita gente que alega que
alumínio, né, protege contra as linhas
de Hatman, mas isso tem gente que tem um
pão X, outros têm Y
e é bem complicado de confirmar isso.
Bem, pessoal, eu separei aqui um um
artigo. Deixa eu ver se eu acho ele
aqui.
Pera aí. Acho que eu deixei aqui o
artigo.
Eu acho interessante.
Ué, cadê? Será que eu perigi isso?
Me deem só um instante, pessoal.
Estranho. Ah. Tá aqui, eu tinha colocado
em outro lugar.
Bem, pessoal, o que eu queria discutir
com vocês aqui é sobre irradiação
ultravioleta do sangue. Sabe aquela
sensação gostosa quando você toma um
banho de sol pela manhã, aquele
bem-estar que a gente sente com o calor
do sol? Pois é, eu vou contar para vocês
uma história bem interessante sobre como
a luz pode ser usada como remédio
poderoso. E o que é mais impressionante,
essa essa terapia, ela salvou milhares
de vidas no passado, mas foi
praticamente apagada da medicina
moderna.
Vamos imaginar a seguinte cena. Estamos
em 1928
e um sujeito chamado Emet, quem nem
médico era, ele teve uma ideia
interessante. Ele pensou: "E se eu
tirasse o sangue de alguém, passasse luz
ultravioleta nele e devolvesse ao
corpo?" Parecia coisa de filme de ficção
científica, mas olha só que reviravolta.
A irmã de um amigo médico dele estava
morrendo de secemia, né?
generalizada,
que era praticamente uma sentença de
morte no início do século XX.
Então, sem nada perder, eles tentaram a
terapia experimental e
adivinhe, a mulher se recuperou
completamente,
ou seja, a luz ultravioleta conseguiu
eliminar a infecção generalizada.
E aí foram vários casos de sucesso. Nos
anos 1940, hospitais por toda a América
do Norte estavam usando essa técnica
chamada UVBI, que é a sigla inglês para
irradiação ultravioleta do sangue. E os
médicos da época ficaram muito
impressionados com os resultados.
Pacientes que estavam praticamente
batendo as botas com pneumonia, sepse,
poliomelite, se recuperavam em questão
de horas ou dias.
Era considerado praticamente um milagre.
E tem um caso que deixou todos de boca
aberta, um sujeito que tinha trombose no
cérebro, pneumonia,
infecção no sangue, cógulos dos pulmões,
paralisia do lado esquerdo e o coitado
tava realmente uma situação muito
próxima da morte.
Depois de duas sessões de UVBI, nessa
ultravioleta, no sangue, ele não só
sobreviveu, como se recuperou
completamente.
E aí aconteceu uma coisa nos anos 1950,
essa terapia estava eh fazendo sucesso
em mais de 50 hospitais americanos. E aí
a MB, a Associação América Americana,
resolveu interferir. Então eles queriam
comprar os direitos da máquina do Note,
mas ele recusou a vender esses direitos.
Então, a MB publicou um estudo na época,
um estudo muito questionável, dizendo
que a terapia não funcionava
e depois descobriram que nesse estudo
que tava mostrando que a terapia não
funcionava, tinham colocado um filme na
máquina para bloquear a parte da luz da
violeta durante o estudo. Então, os tais
americanos, por causa desse estudo da
MB, abandonaram ao VBI.
E foi bem na época que os antibióticos
estavam chegando com força total, né,
nos anos 50. E enquanto isso na Rússia e
na Alemanha, as pesquisas continuaram
e persistiram utilizando a terapia.
E a razão é que nesses países tinha
menos recursos para essa
eh questão aí dos antibióticos estavam
começando a surgir nos Estados Unidos.
E realmente eu conheço um médico aqui em
São Paulo que usa essa essa terapia com
infra ultravioleta sanguíneo e ele me
fala que tem bons resultados e pode
tratar uma lista muito grande de
doenças, infecções bacterianas graves,
hepatite, problemas cardíacos,
atritumide
e parece que até mulheres com abortos
repetidos
conseguiram levar a gravidez ao termo
depois de tratamento.
Então, o que que a luz ultravioleta faz?
Além de matar bactérias e vírus, quando
ela entra em contato com sangue,
acontece uma série de reações no corpo,
o sangue fica mais fluido, melhora a
circulação, o sistema imunológico fica
mais ativo e as células meio que ligam o
motor de novo.
Então, durante a pandemia do C19, alguns
médicos corajosos voltaram a usar
ultravioleta. E adivin, funcionou muito
bem. Pacientes graves se recuperavam
mais rápido, saíam do hospital em metade
do tempo. Teve até um estudo russo
mostrando que quem fazia o VBI ficava 7
dias a menos no hospital internado, mas
no Brasil não teve estudos e nem nos
Estados Unidos.
E o que chama atenção é que a máquina de
ultravioleta custa
um valor bem acessível, alguns milhares
de reais, e pode tratar milhares de
pacientes.
E existe ainda alguns médicos nos
Estados Unidos ainda utilizando a
técnica para tratar olime, fadiga
crônica, infecções virais persistentes
como epistem bar. E pode funcionar até
em animais, né? Tem médicos veterinários
utilizando com sucesso e salvaram vários
pets com essa terapia.
E realmente o problema, eu acho que
essas máquinas não estão liberadas pela
Anvisa do Brasil. Se eu não me engano,
esse médico meu amigo que tem essa
máquina, ele trouxe isso meio
clandestino.
Isso é bem complicado, então, da gente
utilizar em consultório.
Então, achei interessante dividir isso
com vocês.
O qual motivo melhor? Esperar meia hora
para escovar os dentes após as
refeições.
É para dar tempo das defesas bacterianas
da boca agirem, as enzimas digestivas
também da boca, né? A a
pitialina, né? Que a milá salivara atuar
antes de você usar a escova de dente. E
mais uma questão de equilíbrio
microbiano e de enzimas.
A vacina Efuída 025 é mais eficaz?
Creio que não, Enil. Eu acho que é só
uma questão de marketing.
Escova dental de bambu antifúng. Não
sei, Eliseu. Nunca li nada a respeito.
Isso é é um assunto bem interessante,
sim, pessoal. Ó, esse ultravioleta aí.
Mais alguma pergunta, pessoal?
Zumbido de ouvido pode ter causa
disbiose.
Nunca li nada a respeito. Eliseu
poluição eletromagnética pode
influenciar no zumbido, sim. Não ser
causa primária, mas pode influenciar
sim.
Depois de consumir o orégano por 3
meses, devo esperar quanto tempo para
consumir de novo? Dá um intervalo de um
mês aí sem tomar.
Jejun de 5 dias favorece o crescimento
fúng?
Não. Você leu isso aonde? Acho que não.
Nunca vi nada a respeito.
De nada, néonild? Obrigado ter
comparecido a nossa live aí semanal.
Bem, eu vou pra academia, pessoal,
treinar.
Qual a sua opinião sobre o protocolo
Ruda Clark? Eu uso em alguns pacientes,
não acho ele a última Coca-Cola de
gelada do deserto. Muitas vezes eu
prefiro usar uma terapia muito mais
simples com antiparasitário de farmácia
mesmo, tá? Eu acho que ele é ultra
valorizado esse protocolo. Eu não sou
contra ele, mas eu acho que ele é usado
exageradamente, sem necessidade.
Ele tem coisas muito boas nesse
protocolo, mas ele é meio complicadinho
e não acho que seja necessário ficar
usando ele o tempo todo, não.
Tem muita gente que acha que os anti
parasitários de farmácia não são
eficientes e acho que o protocolo da
Roda Clark é quase milagroso. não
concordo com essa situação.
Tá
bem, pessoal? Obrigado por ter assistido
essa live ao vivo. Quem não assistiu
sabe que pode assistir depois, fica
gravado.
Desejo a vocês uma excelente semana pela
frente e vamos nos vendo, tá?
quinta-feira, provavelmente, eu vou
fazer uma live aberta, aviso para vocês.